[Music]
foreign
of water resources and the provision of
high quality drinking water is a key
priority for public health the federal
Safe Drinking Water Act protects the
public from Legacy well-known
contaminants however
there are certain chemicals which we
call emerging contaminants that might be
present in our drinking water emerging
contaminants represent a special
challenge because the very limited
availability of information regarding
them and most importantly they are not
regulated by federal or state 1.4
dioxane is a stabilizer that has been
used with many organic solvents that it
is difficult to be filtered from the
drinking water
so whatever there was a chemical spill
of solvents the 1.4 dioxane was with
them and it has been detected in several
superfan sites uh throughout the United
States and internationally Superfund
sites are areas that there is a
contamination a chemical spill or
environmental release of chemicals by
the chemical industry we decided to
develop a research center primarily
focusing on this chemical the Yale super
fund reset Center aims to study the role
of 1.4 dioxane in human health as well
as better methods of detecting it in the
environment and also better ways of
mitigating that from the drinking water
based on studies 1.4 dioxane is a
probable human carcinogen therefore we
are aiming to study the molecular
mechanism by which 1.4 dioxane along or
with its co-contaminants may cause
cancer and at the same time we are
aiming to develop biomarkers of exposure
to this can Vehicles since there is no
epidemiological studies confirming the
carcinogenicity of this compound in
humans Dr Diesel and her colleagues are
investigating the exposure assessment of
1.4 dioxane in human populations project
two is an exposure assessment study
which is the study of how people come
into contact with chemicals as they move
through their everyday lives this could
be pollutants in the air that they
breathe chemicals and the food they're
eating the personal care products
they're using or even contaminants in
their drinking water it's really
important to understand what people are
exposed to so we have to know who is
exposed to what amounts certain
populations may have higher levels of
these chemicals in their drinking water
or in their blood and that will help us
understand whether or not they're at
risk for any health problems our study
area includes two counties on Long
Island Nassau and Suffolk counties and
these two counties are home to dozens of
state and federal super fun sites we're
going to hundreds of homes on Long
Island to interview people about the
consumer products they're using collect
their drinking water and test it for
chemicals collect blood samples to look
for health markers and map where people
live in relation to hazardous waste
sites another reason why exposure
assessment is so important is because by
identifying communities with higher
levels of exposures that can help direct
some of the interventions so some of the
other projects in the Superfund Center
are developing treatment devices that
could be deployed in homes that have
particularly high levels of 14 dioxane
or other chemicals in their drinking
water one for dioxin is a very typical
pollutant to treat if it is in
groundwater because it's so tiny and it
loves water it doesn't like to stick to
the surface so because of the property
the conventional muscle to treat
pollutants does not work well for one
for dioxane we are trying to use
electricity and electric power is going
to produce oxidation power meaning
destruction power destruction of one for
dioxane by hydroxyl radical is a proven
chemistry but it is extremely difficult
to realize in a smaller scale setting
for in this Center what we are trying to
do is to make a small modular system for
users point of view you just plug in
connect the pipe and it destroys one for
dioxin that's the goal and we are at the
initial stage of realizing that goal so
one critically important aspect of the
Superfund Center is the community
engagement core and I'm leading that
along with Adrian Esposito who is the
executive director of citizens campaign
for the environment which is a large
Grassroots organization
based in Long Island that has a long
history of working on drinking water
quality issues in the study area it's a
very rich partnership between the
university and the community and the
community is directly providing input
into the science so as scientists we're
not just going into communities and and
studying what we think is important
we're asking the people who live there
and what they're concerned about and
their their concerns and ideas are
directly informing our research
questions and our science doing the
science is incredibly important but once
once the work is done and the results
are in it's really important to format
the results and information in a way
that's useful to the community and to
policy makers it is very important that
we inform stakeholders and legislators
regarding
toxic limits of those emerging
contaminants in our drinking water So
eventually we would like to inform
policy on setting up standards for our
drinking water
foreign